mr. coca today ah I'm wearing my best
zombie killer shirt but my worst zombie
killing pants cuz it's uh they're like
white or light gray and white shoes
because our killing zombies today well
the game are called dying light the
following now look um here's the deal
I'm not gonna lie to you why would I lie
to you Beth I lie to you actually all
the time I was cleaning my apartment and
found this game on the floor and someone
gave it to me for free so that's why
we're playing it today I say you know I
believe in omens I believe in signs you
know I believe like you see a crow
flying and it means you should buy a
lotto ticket that's the thing from Game
of Thrones so I was cleaning my
apartment and I was like oh well I just
found this game we got to play a game
it's October scary tober as they call it
nobody calls it scary tober so we're
playing or playing this and I'm wearing
a light gray pants hello hon sooth
slacks sorry these music slacks they're
weirdly clingy which I'm not I keep
doing this all day they're weirdly
clingy okay anyway let's play a little
dying light little zombie action mystery
still going by the state of happy
everybody what do you called you call it
what do you call it October October yes
fair enough
hey so me from Lithuania hey Leah Rose
hey what's up asian asian anonymous good
to see you I look like a grandpa this is
Madeleine since that's a pretty cool
grandpa that's really really cool icon
Miami Florida grandpa yes that's right
my eye that's today today I'm dressed
like I'm Miami Florida it's 94 here in
Los Angeles hello oh hello from London I
love it
look at this Jack yeah okay it's we're
just gonna eventually turn this into a
fashion Street
which I will take October's good your
order sir locate the target okay Steph
you're it eliminated I don't have where
like gray slacks and you're wearing this
kind of shirt you don't have any
patience
no no why is there even a sister we all
know zombies
oh I don't care about this who cares the
Bozak chord let's play oh look at this
is Los Angeles present day by the way
yeah a lot of stuff going on Leon smug
and father Oh be the zombie oh yeah
let's do it we're gonna be the zombie
guys zombies oh oh this looks awesome
that guy's definitely got some kind of
eggs upon his face there rosacea I know
dude I love this we're gonna be the
zombie guys Cody my day's going well
thank you for joining us this is dying
like the following which is a game I
found somebody gave me for free and
we're playing and I found it on my floor
last night so we're doing it uh hello
from Saudi Arabia good to see you uh
what is everybody's favorite horror game
I've really been liking the Friday the
13th game lately I love me some alien
isolation although first hour super slow
we might we might switch to Friday 13th
of the games if this game sucks all
right whoo look at this yeah invasion of
the night hunter this tutorial will
familiarize with the basic skills and
abilities the night hunter all right
yeah look at this running what's
happening here
can I do something move to the
highlighted markers no got it yeah is it
weird I'm scaring myself then this game
is all about parkour you know you know
our core is I think this park in French
you know I think it means like it's
based I call it freestyle walking you
know yeah I think that's just the whole
thing all right a tendril locomotion you
use tendrils to move even faster in gym
you're sprinting called Elbe to shoot
the floor okay oh Jesus Christ
yeah you're like basically Spider Man
but you want to eat brains
by the way missed opportunity to have
Spider Man like do come to some messed
up stuff you know yeah oh my god that's
a weird I feel I have a feeling I'm
gonna get killed very quickly with this
thing I don't I'm not feeling good about
my chances
why does Ami's have to see in black and
white you know hey wow dude what's up
why can't you subscribe to our channel
BMW I don't know there's an emotes thing
happening oh yeah oh yeah cuz you know
why we don't believe in charging people
for our channel because we believe we're
volunteers we don't even work at Conan
this wallpaper it's 3d yeah three guys
it's uh yeah it's like plastic that's
right it's also it's a musical
instrument because we love who enjoyed
the musical instrument the vegetable
musician one of my favorite clips in
recent memory vegetable musician so good
oh wait let's kill this dude
ah wait I went past him what happened
hey Jesus all right
that's fun you know I now see why
zombies are so angry I mean you don't
really get to see much of the world you
know you can't appreciate good art oh
wait I guess now I can see colors yeah
it's a lot of bugs fair enough
well what can oh I can invade other
players games oh this is gonna be really
fun I guess this tutorial is over uh hey
what's up Omar isn't a messed up
spider-man just venom well then it was
more of a symbiote right so he's venom
himself is actually just not a person
it's an alien thing right who's excited
though for Tom Hardy's venom that's
gonna be dope so I can't go up this this
is very my tendrá I need good tendril
work there we go cool little glitch
glitch can I just get up here please
Jesus all right good pounce attack whoo
my main weapon dispatched a victim one
shot got it exit is
let's pounce on something all right is
there a dude somewhere I can pounce on
gonna Tom Hardy and anything is tough I
agree
oh yeah Oh get him oh yes
Oh dope that's great that's pretty great
that's pretty great
here's the thing you know what I gotta
say something the whole thing about
zombies to me is wait those are other
things right there on a pounce on these
things no that's us oh we care about
this though we're good
oh he's trying to get in there that
screw him up or something um he exploded
that was beautiful said Madeline since
the orange I count on the map um I see
all right hiyee
ooh got it oh man am i dead already
ah Jesus you be like you dick successful
ground-pound hold Artie than release
perfect
so wait this guy all this is is a
flashlight that's hurting me
wait this is this
get me out of here bro whoo that was no
fun so this we're seeing is I can't get
a suntan that's pretty that sucks the
light burns yeah all right fair enough
he was gonna be great color okay
he's hey Poland what's up jan-jan good
to see you hmm I feel like I don't know
if I'd be a good zombie cuz I'm pretty
lazy you know I feel like zombies are so
like motivated they always want never
seen a zombie like run away they right
he's so dumb that they get killed right
you know like and I would never do my
like zombie homework I didn't apply
myself in school guys that's why I have
to play video games for a living you
know that's why I'm not doing something
cool like being a doctor or something
I'm just not smart you know I'm probably
straight your nest but uh God see now
we're getting into the whole thing
I just is there a game I can just go and
just kill everything oh I see oh I see
what this game is gonna be now all right
yeah Oh counts your ass
okay Natak there really looks like I'm
having sex with them which I'm not
totally opposed to you because those
guys are kind of you know hot and like a
you know the kind of a rugged way you
know like I bet those guys shop at REI
you know yeah yeah Birkenstocks like an
REI kind of dude you know it's pretty
hot and I gotta say if you're into like
the rugged dudes I mean that's the whole
thing apply myself now is this smile boy
all right I'm trying Jesus hmm there's
some people over here I'm supposed to
murder
yeah what's up what's up are they up
here yep I II know also all these guys
look exactly the same they're all just
like a hot I wonder if yeah they all
look like you know what maybe that's cuz
it's the tutorial
it is literally the same guy all right
fair enough
uh hey hey thanks oh hey thanks Oh
pep-pep it's also these clingy pants
make me look thinner look at these look
at these look at y'all clean you want to
touch my leg yeah I got bet to touch my
leg dude he's looking up okay so let's
use let's let's go to the quick join
menu I think we kind of get it here oh I
can't wait damn it
quick join though can I do the quick
join hey uh quick join him quick joy hey
I'd like to do uh okay fair enough by
the way what is this they want me this
my resume they want me to show my resume
in here CV what's the big deal you can't
see it oh you're missing my resume joke
because the inside box but guys the
whole thing was instead of resume its
resume get it yeah come on that's fun
come on we're just having some yucks
here guys get her number Beth won't give
me your number
she also like sits next to me so yeah
let's go so how many is there like a
story mode here or pounce yay I like the
fact that you jump up after the pounce
because that's real fun
you know what now nice REI flashlight
sucka Oh are these all oh this is
awkward what's happening here you guys
you guys good or guys I don't know it
looks like I don't want to interrupt him
it looks like they're busy doing yeah
maybe this just like they're getting
like a zombie massage or something
it looks vaguely like dirty what's
happening there I don't know I'm
uncomfortable with that whole situation
Nicolas Patterson is lagging smile more
uh Beth is not forced to sit next to me
are you we just kind of chose our own
seats yeah there's a wall separating
it's a low one yeah
there's a low wall but it's a wall so
you know also you know we use noise
cancelling headphones we don't talk
during the day which is probably better
shirt of the day jungle Germania this is
a old navy shirt I got it Old Navy and
the thing about this shirt it I'm
leaving the playable area think about
this shirt is now looks like a Hawaiian
shirt but it's got a bunch of cacti on
it or cactuses if you don't like grammar
and so my question is is this a Hawaiian
shirt if it's got desert stuff on it
that's really the question Vincent turbo
there you go you got your shoutout is
there some sort of oh man we got some UV
light happening up here is there gonna
be a situation where I get to have some
kind of a story
or just kill the same dude over and over
you know oh I'm doing myself a
disservice by not playing the main game
mode first
all right fade to one fair enough but do
I get to play the zombie in the main
game mode these guys don't even turn
around by the way when did their their
friends can kill they just still yeah
well don't attack me
alright fine I'll play the main game
mode I could show you my resume but
whatever is their quest progress
happening
there's no quest progress going on
session options Oh what is this oh now
we're in this hell so you normally play
my own thing alright ok I get it I get
it in order to play my own account but
today we're not yeah I got it can I get
out of here please what's happening give
me get out get me out of this
invisibility sure single-player got it
let's leave this alright uh ok fair
enough I'm gonna go in the main game
mode guys zombie thing looks tacked on
it does a little bit fade to one but I
was just so excited because you know you
never get to get inside the mind of the
zombie yeah here we go
um ok fair enough play campaign look at
this is like the Golden Hour look at
this guy like the light beautiful in
here
I'm gonna tell you right now I have a
feeling this game is gonna have like a
tutorial that's gonna be like 45 minutes
this get this doesn't this game feel
like it's gonna be one of these and like
I love like I have to say I love huge
games like I love like red dead
redemption i love your Skyrim's i like
fallout on this stuff but what they do
well is i feel like their tutorials are
kind of mixed in you can still jump into
some crazy [ __ ] immediately you know
whereas this game feels to me like it's
gonna be a lot of like we need somebody
extracted and it's gonna take you an
hour and we're gonna show you and we're
gonna make you crawl before you can walk
kind of a thing you know
ah meme Batista
yep zombies have a mind they do and I'm
playing them yeah I agree Marriott er I
mean I don't need see look at this
oh my god we're getting it just start me
in the game man you don't need to do
this whole thing like I knew it
see there's gonna be an identify the
conflict I knew it I just could feel it
he'll be to skip thank you game makers
please do me a favor maker tutorial it's
like how you know what they used to do
guys I'm old but you know what they used
to do is they used to put a little
booklet in the thing and it would teach
you how to play the game now that seems
stupid then they stopped doing that
because they started creating tutorials
into games right okay here's the problem
well they put tutorials into games when
they when they just had the booklet in
the game in in the physical game you
could just not read it and then you
could just start playing the game and
you would get right into the game yeah
okay then they put tutorials into the
game being like oh this will be so much
easier cuz it'll teach somebody how to
play no I don't care I don't read the
instructions when I put together IKEA
furniture that's why it takes me twice
as long and it's really frustrating but
it comes out upside down which literally
I did do with my bookshelf but also you
just get right into it
I'm just saying action you know I would
rather oh great I've received a new
outfit I don't care about that gotta
look good when running from zombies I'm
the kind of guy who and this is not I'm
not proud of this but I'm the kind of
guy who instead of like sitting in
traffic I'll just take the surface roads
even though it takes me longer because
at least it's the illusion of progress
you know oh my god here's this guy
alright
oh my god I can't do anything yeah I
know how to use a controller man by the
way like if you're starting your
videogame career with this game no like
I think it's funny like I think all
video games in a certain way think that
you're picking up a video game for the
very first time you know like give us a
little credit no and a guy with the soul
patch this is already terrible just the
facial hair in this game already is
scarier than any other game I play and
then when you restart mariotta says then
when you restart a game you play before
him there's no skip tutorial it's the
worst I agree funny story when we shot
the clueless gamer for Skyrim I've told
this story many times because it
illustrates my point perfectly you know
video games are not really made to shoot
comedy bits with and so I deeds yo
what's up hey guys doing you guys guys
ever go on bumble yeah okay cool later
uh we're playing Skyrim and we did a
thing where oh we got a we got it we got
to stop this we got it we got to turn
these notifications off right now
where we started the game in the
beginning of Skyrim you're in a cart and
you're being taken to a thing and you
take it to like an execution thing and
all this stuff and it takes 15 minutes
and that's before you can choose your
character so we were doing it and what
is happening here what I need to do is
take off well I'm just gonna give up in
about a second anyway and we kept
playing it we had to keep playing it
because Conan wanted to name his
character different things we played it
three times
it took us 45 minutes to literally just
do that part of the game because we
couldn't skip the tutorial never since
then guys I've hated tutorials go see
the boss in room 190 oh my god what come
on
this is [ __ ] I'm gonna go up and see
the boss and if it's a long talking
thing I'm quitting and I'm gonna play
Friday the 13th
cuz let me tell you something about
Friday the 13th and that's a game that
just puts you right into the mix I hate
this I hate this I hate this I hate this
I hate this I hate this aah
Schiphol B to skip all right great just
put me in with the zombies man come on
one of the greatest zombie movies ever
28 days later just starts with
creepiness there's no like now we're
looking at the city can I jump off and
kill myself me that would get things
going what I have to do now oh check for
the lost survivor in the worst hey
Katzenjammer o6 good to see you also I
would say you guys should also add just
me personally blurt B le y AE er T
because we normally play on my gamertag
so if you want to play with us that's
the way to do it
oh my god this is just I can you have
like 30 minutes of run and jump tutorial
all right I think I feel like we should
quit this who wants to quit this yea or
nay quit it I can't I can't do I can't
do 30 more minutes of this I can't do it
bare steel last of us started kind of
slow aah did it I feel like it did not
start kind of slow because the first
thing in the Last of Us is where shit's
going haywire and you have to run from
all that [ __ ] with Joel and and his
daughter so the Last of Us you're wrong
it did not start slow it started great
Oh No
alright wait this could actually get
good this could get good play until dawn
yeah they're saying quick quick quick
quick
Friday 13th quit quit quit yeah
Cody you're right you go the last of us
went to hell like immediately cuz this
is what I want when playing a video game
to watch a movie for 15 minutes oh I got
bitten you better get your hands on some
antidote yep never seen this in a plot
before oh wait I've seen it in every
plot ever okay now wait a second here we
go alright guys wait a second I got a
thing now and now I'm running around I
got a pipe or something by the way like
I love like these games or they're like
it's a putt yeah it's killing let's kill
it let's go oh that was so I supposed to
help this dude by the way guys quick
plug I just started watching mine Hunter
great show on Netflix it's awesome dude
Fisher's new show
it's about serial killers it's amazing
alright Friday people want Friday 13th
all right you know what I don't know man
let's just let's we might figure this
out here it's not that I'm a quitter I'm
just impatient and a quitter
you know that's the thing so yeah you
just want to plug the HDMI into the
other thing Thanks
before you go to the game we'll get the
game started well before we go to the
game uh so Beth what is your review of
undying light oh cool this is great
undying light the following which is a
game we just played and to be fair I
just I found it I found it on my floor
last night
I was cleaning my apartment and I
thought it was a sign I really did think
it was like an omen we should play this
game but now I'm thinking maybe that
wasn't such a great in terms of things
you can find in the floor it's not true
very true that's true
although there are a lot of socks on my
apartment floor because that's why I was
cleaning it yeah a lot of socks there's
you know one one time I found a piece of
not recently guys but I found a piece of
apple pie under my bed in black because
you know sometimes yours eating apple
pie guys follow me this one sometimes
you're just sitting on the floor eating
some apple pie and then you know someone
gives you color you're like oh you just
kind of slide it under the bed that's in
the photo you know you just don't want
it like right in front of you you know
when you're because you're talking and
then you don't want it because it was
just keep beating us you take it away
from where you are and and then and the
reason why we're stalling is because you
turn on the ps4 we hadn't updated so we
have to update but yes so last week
quick update on our show we went to New
York City we shot some remotes for our
upcoming week of shows at the Apollo
we're very excited we got a lot of great
guests coming we have a lot of exciting
comedy plans so if you're following team
Coco on Instagram which why wouldn't you
be at Team Coco and team Coco on
snapchat at Team Coco and at Conan
O'Brien and Tim Cook on Twitter and then
Facebook you saw what we did there we
did a couple fun things I'm not gonna
see him on here because you should go to
her social yeah you have to find out and
check him out but I will say one of the
really fun things about New York is
there's so much to do there Conan had a
show there for years yeah and then we've
been back many times since and there
still is great delicious comedy to be
mind and also Conan went on Colbert
which was very The Late Show
I told the story about David Letterman
giving him a horse which I'm really sad
I missed it when it was here I didn't
know that happened we didn't know that
he gave him a horse and then it was
right here and and he also told a great
story about
which is one of my favorite stories
about his Harvard ring when he was
playing a basketball and then he told
the story which is really funny which I
think I don't know if I told on here yes
the live Q&A yeah which you guys should
watch because then you get to see stuff
before it's on Colbert yeah but about
which was a true story about when we
went to the Church of the Nativity of
Bethlehem and just hit an oil lamp with
this boom and actually I was right
behind him when that happened and so my
clothes also got covered in oil so I
guess I have like holy oil on my shorts
yeah like all over my shorts but the
best part of that story to me was the
fact Ike you know where we are a very
very tight schedule it's rebuilding the
database now that's great actually do
you wanna can you go to the inset box
just for a second this is what's
happening that's good
you can go fullscreen and so the best
story of that to me is so what happens
is we go into this very holy place he
hits the the this lamp with a boom oil
goes everywhere you know it's just
horribly embarrassing then we leave and
he's covered in oil and we go outside
and we had like a very tight schedule
where when we're on this on these when
we're on these travel shows and so we
have to go we gotta go we gotta go so he
couldn't do anything so he just rings
out his shirt it just it's like he was
just swinging or something and he rings
out his shirt out of all the oil and
then and then we have to get back in the
van and we're traveling in like these
two chevy lumina x' and we have to get
back in the van and go to the next
location and so he gets in the van to
let his shirt off without his shirt and
we're all crammed in this band and like
every part of his body is like touching
our Associate Producer Ruthie's but and
we're just there and I took this photo
and I'm not gonna look it up on my phone
but I have this great photo so I was
sitting right behind him just a
shirtless muniya who's like Ian
the van just like this covered in oil
and then he put a shirt back on and we
did like 20 we shot like 20 more things
that day which is hilarious
so quite a little problem we have which
is you know there's a 13 minutes left 40
minutes yeah but I think I don't know if
we can play this game without the
network features yeah we could try it I
don't think it's gonna work let's go to
shop
Friday the 13th people don't update your
game so much what's up sound man not
allowed in holy places it Stanton
exactly I love it anyone says you should
save a dying light now it's gonna
download updates the end of the stream
we can still go back to dine light don't
make me do it I'll do it in a second but
yeah what I Cody says would you
recommend Friday 13th saving way for new
PC is it a good game friar 13 is great
except for the fact you have to update
it now we're gonna see if we could play
this game I'm hoping we can it's super
fun I really like this game a lot for a
lot of reasons but is it gonna let us
play as a question alright let's try to
play now here's the thing guys if you
have added me blurt on PlayStation and
you have this game let me know in the
chat if there's enough people will play
a private match or we can all play
together if this is gonna work at all
let's see if it does the answer is no
the button but no working as the credits
button or private match does the credits
button works let's see you ask the
credits button works
but this does not I love it
but jerks hey go fullscreen for a sec
would you
so yeah so that's hilarious now we can
also play one of my other favorite games
oh you know what let's play this game
this is a fun game oh wait we can play
this too Emily wants to play dear Esther
you should try this game sure close it
cuphead is a really fun game we played
it with we play with Kate Upton it was
great
play tutorial so but yeah so anyway so
there's a perfect story for you guys oh
don't play Emily wants to play bad max I
played layers of fear yeah it's fun Cody
layers of fear is fun
Vincent erm I should play The Last of Us
with Conan Conan is I mean I think I
might be wasted on him and also like I
think the beauty of yeah I agree it's
like emotionally it's not a game also
it's not a game I really yeah it's not
really a game I want to make fun it's
too good right it's like I don't want to
sit there and rip up like Citizen Kane
you know like even with the - Conan yeah
where's Friday 13th Chloe it's updating
its updating is the problem it's
updating and this is loading this is a
mess Emily wants to play as hoarder well
good this will be horror then sonic
adventure - I gotta say the sonic the
new Sonic game is great the one done by
fans it's really great alright here we
go
way nicer than my place alright okay
look at us circles
alright and maybe we're gonna eat food
or something what's the point of this
game exactly can I do anything
they're so sour you hearing a sound oh
that's good
now that's fine now this is it's totally
cool I don't care no no that's fine
don't worry uh Manor says hey why did
you guys never do a close game about
breath of the wild well I gotta say um a
lot of clueless gamers are about timing
with him and by the time week he had it
in a schedule to do breath of the wild
there were just other games to be done
well so I'll say - breath of the wild
it's hard when you when you're doing
close gamer a game that's scary by the
way no flat-screen TV shows static that
doesn't happen you don't see snow
anymore that's not a thing that's like
an old the reason why there's the reason
why there's snow is because it's a tube
from a tube TV it doesn't have you it
just doesn't do anything it just blew or
it's just purple or something yeah so
Emily wants to play get your [ __ ]
together
sound oh really I would want to try
playing this game without sound not so
far so if I'm just walking around
nothing's happening oh this is scary
blue screen of death this is actually a
pretty scary this is scary I think then
Oh creepy dolls aah dude you're getting
Adele get it singer you're getting it
you can hear it well good windows 98 son
oh really
Cody says there is snow in a dead
Channel all right I will say this game
is a lot less scary when you can't hear
anything
hey it's a flashlight guy pick it up or
what's up nope alright cool great can I
only stay within the light no I don't
have to all right can't do anything sure
I can't pick up this flashlight oh here
we go got it
l1 Oh got it okay good all right here we
go all right well now we've set the
scene for the house to be all dark you
know was a great game Resident Evil 7
that's a really fun scary game that can
be scared the [ __ ] out of me I also
played it on PlayStation VR and it was
like one of the one of the most scary
things that's ever happened to me in my
life besides getting a blue screen of
death when I was writing a term paper Oh
a mirror fell out well this just looks
like a poorly hung mirror what is up
with all these dolls in the house I
don't know man I don't think dolls are
that's scary I'm gonna be honest you
know but I will say you know it's scary
is a poorly grouted tub yeah you know
leaks water damage can really damage
your home guys hi I'm Erin Blair if you
hate water if you hate getting your
stuff destroyed grout your sinks
Oh No ah it's a clock oh it's midnight
there it's a pizza a my daddy just so
what happened here
should I put this right I don't know all
right well I don't pack these boxes
clearing those battlegrounds hey Joker
what's up what's up Joo
Emily's a bit clingy in this game know
that it's kind of scary uh okay oh wait
a second Emily wants to play what does
it say oh that's probably from Emily cuz
the game is called Emily wants to play
and now we have a note and it says I
just want to play I'm guessing Emily
wrote that note guys I don't want to say
that I'm the world's greatest detective
cuz that's Batman and I'm not gonna say
I'm the world's second greatest
detective cuz that's Sherlock Holmes but
I will say I'm a pretty goddamn good
detective when it comes to games so
oh cool now I'm outside ooh oh no I
guess I'm in the garage there's a bulb
the shittiest disco I've ever been in
well the faulty wiring in this house
that's again very scary
so no grout in the tub scary because
water damage number two faulty wiring is
gonna set you back that's a good 10
grand I mean electricians are not cheap
especially a good one
so I'm guessing this game is a horror
game for homeowners somebody's leaving
their laptop on without any without
plugging in oh hey my pizza's always
hear this but you know what it's not
here so it's a scary it's a horror game
also what's on the pizza what are we put
on our pizza ah hey
oh the pizzas coming dude that was Gary
wait is that what happened
are we dead do we die this game should
be renamed Emily wants pizza all right
everybody aah oh my god yeah that was
Emily let's go back and see Friday 13th
is finished loading yet I don't get
Emily's deal like yeah what's your deal
I'm late like was Emily our child
I needed actually you know what I hate
to even say this I needed a bit of a
backstory there I you know what I hate
to eat my words I hate to eat my words
but I think I needed a little bit of
backstory um you can have one track is
going back and putting that scream at a
half half speed ahead pineapple on it I
don't find with pineapple on pizza I
mean it's not my faves but I'll do a
little sweet and savory you know so I'm
hoping this is finished uploading Oh
baby here we go now here's the problem
we're gonna need to hear this I'm
definitely gonna need to hear this game
this is the whole point so while this is
happening let's uh let's go to little
settings I think we did something weird
with the settings here with the audio
perhaps isn't this exciting guys just
looking looking at this audio output
settings HDMI out it's telling me that's
fun
yeah ooh no signal yay
Jason O'Malley's a total genius I'm
ready let's go oh this game is so fun
guys
oh don't leave lobby okay here we go I'm
ready uh sounds better I broke it we're
back now we played at one point we
played with one of the developers you
made this game and cuz I was like uh you
know cuz I ever once a while get lucky
and kill somebody or they'll kill me or
something
I mean people kill me all the time this
game actually really freaks me out I'm
not lying
but he killed like five people in the
span of ten seconds it was insane he
like pulled the dude out of a car and he
like pitchfork to dude in the eye
ooh alright guys here we go
nervous nervous oh boy here we go here
we go dead by daylight I've never heard
of that game techno wolf should I play
that game should try and kill Jason I'm
gonna try Chloe here we go I'm gonna try
I'll play dead by daylight ooh but not
right now I want to get some game
playing into this stream you know oh
here we go
nervous gulp damn it come on scary one
two eighty underscore underscore ytb
yeah dick here we go we're in let's go
let's go let's play ahh scary one you're
killing me bro
scream it's got some lag there the cabin
hey what did Steve say I'd like to
address the big issue dentist trying to
talk to I put stuff in your mouth
I agree Steve you're playing this
weekend I'm like yeah I need to go to
the dentist
Oh Oh guys it's getting a little dark in
here dang nice oh my god let's play
you're killing me
oh come on dudes Jase is just gonna kill
you anyway
Beth is hidden in shadow Oh dead by
daylight was the original title of Evil
Dead is that truth is enough here we go
oh it's grocery sack Jason I love that
look there we go let's go let's go
scared Oh God
darkus [ __ ] what's happening here
I go in here please
can you open the freaking person
oh [ __ ] I'm dead I'm dead
get the thing dude open the thing please
to darken here
[Music]
oh god he's already after me what the
[ __ ] man do I did I get anything that
sucked
I mean it was really scary but you know
need some like weapons or something man
I hate this game why am I playing this
game I hate this game
I hate this dumb game
yeah I can curse in the stream you like
dumb things
dum-dum-dum we go to the boat try to get
that boat but I like got to find the
propeller and stuff right
oh man uh I hate this game
Oh guys you know what play gets real
people makes it so much worse for some
reason fact like that Sonia is like
haunted hunting you down fortify it or
defy it
boom all right let's find something ah
we got a back good good good we got
something
nothing
nothing cool sucks is there any kind of
like propeller or anything in here
nothing cool pretty excited about it
great carpet now this is a weird wall
it's someone should smash through I
guess
oh [ __ ] bear trap trap his ass where's
the door can't find my way out of the
dump cabin oh man I'm so screwed alright
here we go
I put can't put this down
how do I place this
blared figure it out come on dude oh I
hate this come on put the thing down
idiot you know what don't you're right
well done can I can I just
there we go
that's right baby oh god is he coming
great oh wait there's just another door
right here uh Laird's okay well whatever
uh okay we got to find some [ __ ] I'll
bet we gotta find this boat situation I
don't think there's anything in here for
the boat the door opening will spring
the trap damn it
cool I spend like the first 10 minutes
of this game like just opening and
closing doors and [ __ ] did you close to
me is he close to me is he somewhere you
guys uh ah stop it oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he's
down that road he was chasing me no he's
not
oh god oh god oh god it's right behind
me or something the problem is he can
like morph in this game which is really
scary
Oh Oh what was that noise no real bad
noise I never know if I should be near
people are not in your people you know I
think the wrench is better and a bat
what's this a pan
Awesome's getting killed outside oh
Christ I'm out of here man
[Music]
there's a lot of people around here holy
[ __ ] what that why am i running this way
this is the dumbest place to run maybe
he's not gonna see me Oh God
let's get this house oh my god okay I'll
take this knife guys where should I go
what should I do
I'm super nervous Oh God
I don't like to when I try to get to the
boathouse or something I don't know what
do you guys think I'm not finding any
pieces for anything but me that's
because I'm just too far away from
everyone
ah [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that I don't
need that man I don't need that oh I
don't need that at all
God what the hell dude
should I hide what do you guys think I
should do here stress levels rising
where's my stress level I'm in the light
though right
No
if I'm in the light oh yes police all
right I'm gonna go hide cheese please
stop doing that
very scary I'm just gonna hide in here
right till the cops get here
then we're all good in the hood baby how
do I please you got you you can't keep
doing that to me
okay keep running you say okay I'm gonna
keep writing not hide you don't hide
should I run or hi guys hi this is like
so [ __ ] by the way I'm right by the
thing so I think I can leave basically
basically as soon as the cops get here
right oh my god what do I do
this is a mistake what am i doing I
shouldn't run away from the thing
running circles in the middle of the
road
is that a good thing
is this good for me to just stand here
like this in the light this is a good
idea right just hide in the closet
everyone's saying hide okay hide under
the bridge oh Jesus Christ
that's really not good I'm just gonna
hide in here man please stop it girl
you're killing me a place to hide in
here somewhere there's no place to hide
cool oh this is so cool
I'm like in the dark though nah man
hiding is a bad idea okay all right
usually he gets radar when you hide
crouch we don't run high don't be okay
with the timer he could find me there oh
man really man the chat I love you guys
if you're killing me you're killing me
can you see if I'm in a thing can you
see if I'm in here
hiding is the best idea oh my god Weezy
Mac I can't take off my clothes oh god
oh my god you guys oh my god
1:42 guys come on oh when I'm in a
building it lights up red oh I hate this
game I hate this game is he close to me
I hear I hear noises stop it oh my god
I'm so sick daddy murdered I'm in the
light does this mean my stress is gonna
go down how do I get my stress to go
down van relatability help me Jesus
Oh God please for the love of God let
the time go faster I need to oh my god
you have to stop doing that it scares me
when she trips guys oh [ __ ] there's
somebody over here - there's so many
hope but you know what I'm gonna go
close to the person because then they
he'll go after them wait why is this
person somehow got in the river what use
the other person's bait yeah I wish this
game in Valiant
Oh 13 seconds guys this is when Jason
appears by the way I've seen every
horror movie exactly what happens I
don't feel like I'm freaked out here can
I just stand here yeah they're here
don't I just run this way or something
uh guys there's supposed to be cops here
hello yeah I know dude no cops no nice
shorts alright no cops we're so screwed
are the cops in the wrong plate wrong
exit ah no [ __ ] oh alright let's go we
got to go to a different exit oh my god
this sucks
I'm totally stunned ed I'm totally good
other end of the road oh my god
Godspeed Mariano I got my firecrackers
at the ready
you know Jason's just gonna basically be
waiting by the cops that's what I would
do three ways out normally a three ways
great idea but not when it comes to
exiting shouldn't cops appear on the map
they should jungle-gym mania the
question is am i using this player's
bait or as that player using me as been
up looks like we got it there's a Jason
there I my controllers so sweaty I can
barely feel it uh-oh
I saw Jason appear for a second on the
map there he is there is there the cops
by the way she's totally waiting for me
there is look at he's just waiting right
there dick come on dick bring it you
sitting traps
he's like setting traps what a dick I
see you bro
no no get him get with the thing no
dammit dammit
oh god oh man
dammit ah I should have waited for the
girl
[Music]
dammit oh you know what your overall
looks stupid
how about that
[Laughter]
all right I want to see who licked how
many people won
let's see who won who got killed good
Wow so only the girl oh no the girl and
that dude escaped well done guys um guys
that you for joining us for stream Coco
this is super fun join us by the way
Tuesday I think is Halloween next
Tuesday so our next dream right or is
that two streams to Tuesdays I'm sorry
we're gonna play another scary game
please tweet at Team Coco what scared
game we should play next week which will
be super fun and I know these pants are
scary anyway and thank you for joining
us we played a little dialing dying
dying light the following as well as
Friday the 13th and we played Emily
wants to play and we don't want to play
Emily once we played Emily wants pizza
uh and I was super fun guys thank you
for joining us lost in twitch first
McGarry aims coal Xavier Grinch mode
channel in x1 under play Z we'll see you
guys next Tuesday
you